las sirenas que anuncian los ataques han
dejado de marcar el ritmo diario de
izquierda la vida vuelve lentamente a
retomar una normalidad ficticia como lo
recuerdan los bultos de arena que
todavía cubren monumentos emblemáticos
como el de santa olga de kiev si kiev
tiene un gran significado simbólico para
rusia es muy importante para la
propaganda pero también para la
identidad rusa y sobre todo para la
historia que quiere reescribir ahora la
de un nuevo imperio este improvisado
museo al aire libre se ha levantado como
memoria la frustrada ofensiva rusa hacia
la capital ucraniana donde nadie se
siente seguro
la ciudad todavía está al alcance de los
misiles aquí saben bien que quiere es el
premio mayor para el presidente ruso
vladimir putin que días atrás se comparó
con el zar pedro i grande en su ambición
por recuperar lo que considera
territorio ruso
este memorial recuerda que el dolor de
los ucranianos y los habitantes de quiet
no empezó el 24 de febrero empezó en el
2014 aquí hay 11 paneles con cientos de
fotos de hombres y mujeres que han
muerto y solamente van hasta el 2020 and
hope cause tantas a hacer una reconocida
política después de la llamada
revolución de la dignidad en 2014 en su
teléfono guarda la foto del día que
caminó por este mismo lugar con el
entonces vice presidente joe valdez
genius y de ese marco casi draw brand le
dije que mirara a la iglesia de san
miguel que cuando esa catedral fue
construida a comienzos del siglo 11 o
moscú no existía así que cuando putin la
propaganda rusa dice que ucrania es un
estado artificial o que éramos parte de
moscú o rusia no la realidad es que
rusia intenta robar la historia de
ucrania raza estonio creen en history
esta mañana ha interrumpido su agenda
para orar por decenas de amigos que
luchan en la región del donbass donde se
calcula que diariamente mueren alrededor
de 200 personas desde el comienzo a la
invasión su misión ha sido viajar
alrededor del mundo y explicar a los
burócratas internacionales
la importancia de apoyar a los
ucranianos es muy triste ver a algunos
burócratas que se sientan así y tratan
de no escuchar te solo lo hacen como una
reunión protocolaria esto es acerca de
la humanidad su labor se dificulta en la
medida que la posibilidad de una
hambruna alrededor del mundo se hace
mayor y la inflación se dispara pero
para ella como muchos ucranianos esta
también es una lucha por la defensa a la
libertad y la democracia que algunas
sociedades piensan que son eternas